Transcriber: Emre Incel
Gözden geçirme: Nihal Aksakal
Bugün günlerden salı ve bugüne
hepimizin yüklediği bir anlam var.
Bir değer var.
Ama doğada salı yok
ve ne yazık ki bizim yüklediğimiz
anlamların da doğada bir karşılığı yok.
Doğanın ve insanın
momentumu farklı işliyor.
Bu farklılık iyice belirginleşerеk her
gün biraz daha arası açılıyor.
Bu farklılığın nedenlerine, sonuçlarına
geçmeden önce insanın doğadaki yeriyle
ilgili bir ilginç hesap var.
Onu sizlerle paylaşmak istiyorum.
Dünyanın oluşumunun dört buçuk milyar
yıl geriye gittiği biliniyor.
Bu dört buçuk milyar yıllık zaman
dilimini 24 saate indirgediğinizde
ortaya şöyle bir tablo çıkıyor.
Gece yarısı dünya oluşmaya başlıyor.
Sabaha karşı dört civarı
yaşam koşulları ortaya çıkıyor.
Öğleden sonra saat ikide ilk
canlılar, algler dünyayla buluşuyor.
Akşam saat sekizi buluyor
deniz yosunlarının dünyayla buluşması.
Saat yirmi iki elli altı dinozorlar
dünyada yer buluyor
ve yirmi üç otuz dokuz
ilk memeliler ortaya çıkıyor.
Modern insanın dünyada yer bulması
23:59:59,
yani 24 saatlik bir
zaman dilimi içinde insanın varlığı
bir saniyelik bir
zamana tekabül ediyor.
Doğanın momentumu son derece
yavaş, kararlılıkla seyrediyor.
Moleküllerden canlılar,
algler, dinozorlar, memeliler
ve modern insan ortaya çıkıyor.
Bu muazzam evrim içinde insan
diğer canlılardan farklılık sergiliyor.
Bu farklılığın ne olduğu konusunda
muhtelif şeyler ileri sürülebiliyor.
Örneğin düşünen hayvan deniyor
ama biz biliyoruz ki
örneğin bir karga
cam bir şişenin içindeki yiyeceği
bir alet kullanarak çıkartabiliyor
ya da insan konuşan canlıdır deniyor.
Ama hayvanların da kendi aralarında
birbirlerini tehditlere karşı uyararak
haberleştiklerini biliyoruz.
Bence insanı diğer canlılardan asıl ayırt
eden şey, insanın doğanın üstündе,
dışında ve onun efendisi
olarak kendini görüyor oluşu.
Dolayısıyla insan,
doğanın momentumunu reddediyor
ve kendi momentumuna uyarlamaya çalışıyor.
İnsanla doğa arasındaki bu
momentum farkı her zaman böyle olmamış.
Başlangıçta toplayıcılık
ve avcılığa tekabül eden dönemde,
insanoğlu doğanın ritmi ile uyumlu
bir yaşam sergilemek zorunda kalmış.
Çünkü toplayacağı meyveler, sebzeler,
yakalayacağı hayvanlar
hep doğanın ritmi ile uyumlu
olmak zorundaymış.
Ancak o uyumlu oluş
onun varoluşunu mümkün kılabilmiş.
Ne zamana kadar?
Tarımın keşfedilişine kadar.
Tarımla beraber insan toprak üzerinde
bir hakimiyet kurmaya başlıyor.
Gıda üretmeye başlıyor.
Örneğin, domatesi yaz kış yemek istiyor
ya da bir dönüm bir arazide
ne kadar mısır elde edebileceğini
önceden bilmek istiyor.
Bu nedenle seralar yapıyor.
Genetiği ile oynamaya başlıyor bitkilerin.
Depolama ve saklama
koşullarını iyileştiriyor.
Velhasılı, toprak üzerindeki
hâkimiyeti belirginleşmeye başlıyor.
Örneğin, portakal suyu, portakal
suyunu içebilmek için toplamayı,
sonra onu sıkmayı, yapmak zorunda değil.
Artık 7/24 portakal suyuna ulaşabiliyor
ya da dünyanın herhangi bir yerindeki
egzotik meyvelere binlerce kilometre
uzaktan erişebilir hale geliyor.
Doğayla insanın momentumun arasındaki
bu açılış, bu farklılık,
sanayi devrimiyle beraber
daha da belirgin hale geliyor.
Nihayet küreselleşme dediğimiz
içinde yaşadığımız bu dönemde
bu fark artık çok net bir biçimde
karşımıza çıkıyor.
Peki insanlık bu durumdan memnun mu?
Çok memnun olduğumuzu zannetmiyorum
çünkü artık haz almadığımız
bir hızla yaşamaya başladık.
O kadar hızlı yaşıyoruz ki.
Sadece örneğin karnımızı doyurmak
için yemek yiyoruz.
Hızla evden çıkıyoruz.
Hızla işimizi yapmaya gayret ediyoruz.
Hızla eve dönmeye çalışıyoruz.
Her şey hızla ve her şey büyüklükle
ifade edilir bir hale gelmiş durumda.
Hayatımızdaki en makbul değer hız.
Ne kadar hızlısınız o kadar makbulsünüz.
Ama bu hızdan çok haz almıyoruz.
Hızla haz arasındaki ters orantıyı
bir türlü fark etmiyoruz.
Sevdiklerimize zaman ayıramıyoruz.
Dolayısıyla insanlık aslında bu hızdan
çok da memnun değil.
Onun için hepimizin aklının bir köşesinde
bir balıkçı kasabasına yerleşmek
ya da bir dağ köyüne çıkmak,
hayatının geri kalanını orada geçirmek
gibi hayaller var.
Zaten bu hayallerin bilimsel
bir temeli de var.
Michigan Üniversitesi'nin yaptığı
bir araştırmaya göre
insanlar doğaya yaklaştıkça
stres seviyesi azalıyor.
Zihin sağlığı yerine geliyor.
Dolayısıyla hepimizin aklının
bir köşesinde olan bu kaçışın
bir bilimsel temeli de var,
ama yapamıyoruz.
Neden kaçamıyoruz?
Çünkü daha çok para
kazanmamız lazım.
Ödenecek borçlarımız,
kredi kartlarımız, kredilerimiz var.
Ama öyle bir sistem ki, ne kadar
çok kazansak daha çok kazanmak zorundayız.
Sonsuz bir uğraşın peşinde,
beton yuvalarda,
hızla yaşamımızı sürdürmeye çalışıyoruz.
Bazı insanlar bu hızdan memnun
olmadıkları için
ve doğanın ritmine tekrar dönebilmek için
bir mücadele vermeye başladılar.
Bu mücadelede, görüyorsunuz,
kentlerin içinde
son kalan parklara sahip çıkıyorlar.
Zeytinleri savunmaya çalışıyorlar.
Evlerinin balkonlarında
sebze yetiştiriyorlar.
HES'lere karşı mücadele veriyorlar.
Bunlar, doğanın hayatımızdaki
en büyük zenginlik olduğunun farkındalar.
Ama bir başka grup da
gözünü kırpmadan,
örneğin binlerce ağacı katlederek
havaalanı yapmayı düşünebiliyor.
Bu mücadele, yani doğanın ritmine
tekrar sahip çıkmakla,
doğanın ritmine hakim olmayı
düşünenler arasındaki mücadele,
hayatın her anında
her gün onlarca örneğini gördüğümüz
bir mücadele olarak yoluna devam ediyor.
Doğadan uzaklaştıkça
insanların hayat üzerindeki hakimiyeti
ne yazık ki azalıyor.
Daha çok kazanmak için
her şeyin daha büyüğünü yaparak
doğa üzerindeki hakimiyetini
güçlendirmek için,
hayatta hiçbir şeye değer vermeyen
insanlar iktidarlarını perçinliyorlar.
Bu iktidarın savunucuları,
iktidarlarının mutlaklığını
ve kaçınılmazlığını gösterebilmek için
her türlü aracı kullanıyor.
Yeryüzündeki kaynaklar, yeryüzünde yaşayan
bütün insanları besleyebilecek,
giydirebilecek, ev sahibi
yapabilecek kadar zenginken,
yani her türlü ihtiyacımızı
giderebilmesi mümkünken,
açlık ve yoksulluğun
kaçınılmaz olduğunu öğreniyoruz.
Bu öğretilmeye çalışılıyor.
Yeryüzünde vicdan, adalet,
hakkaniyet, merhamet,
özgürlük azaldıkça acı ve gözyaşı büyüyor.
Kibir barışın, kurnazlık bir arada
yaşama kültürünün önüne geçmeye başlıyor.
Ne yazık ki doğadan uzaklaşan
ve insanlığın momentumunu,
doğanın momentumundan
koparmaya çalışan insanlar,
iktidarlarını perçinlemek için,
örneğin,
basını kullanıyor.
Örneğin,
bu iktidarın
enerji için, kalkınma için,
refah için, zenginlik
için olduğunu ifade ediyor.
Ama bu iktidar gücünü perçinledikçe
ve doğadan uzaklaştıkça aslında
rasyonalitesini de yitirmeye başlıyor.
Rasyonalitesini yitirdikçe gaddarlaşıyor.
Daha hırçınlaşıyor.
Onun için tarımsal alanlara,
zeytin ağaçlarına saldırıyor.
Bir gecede on altı bin köyü
Büyükşehir Yasası'yla ortadan kaldırıyor.
Altı bin zeytin ağacını
kesip yok edebiliyor.
Velhasıl, sürdürülebilirliğini yitiren
ve her gün kendi sonunu
daha çok hazırlamaya başlayan
bir akrebe dönüşüyor.
Aslında yapılabilecek şey çok basit.
Yapılabilecek şey, bu muazzam dengenin,
kainatın dört buçuk milyar yılda
oluşturduğu
bu muazzam uyumun
karşısında saygıyla eğilmek,
yüzümüzü ona dönerek o ritmi
tekrar yakalamaya çalışmaktan geçiyor.
Biz Seferihisar'da
bunu yapmaya çalışıyoruz.
Yani tarihin derinliklerinden gelen
erdemleri, değerleri tekrar bugüne,
gün ışığına çıkartmaya çalışıyoruz.
Kalkınmayı bilimin öncülüğünde, doğayı
koruyarak yapabilmenin yollarını arıyoruz.
Böyle olduğu için de
Seferihisar'daki yaptıklarımızdan
kısacık bahsetmek istiyorum
çünkü başka bir dünya mümkün.
Başka bir dünyanın mümkün
olduğunu Seferihisar'da kanıtlıyoruz.
Kelebek etkisine inanıyoruz.
O başka bir dünyanın Seferihisar'dan
başlayarak kurulacağını düşünüyoruz.
Seferihisar'da yola çıkarken
logosu salyangoz olan
ve adı gevurca Cittaslow
olarak ifade edilen
bir yerel kalkınma modelini
vatandaşlarımıza anlatmaya başladık.
İşimiz başlangıçta zordu.
Fakat sonra bu yerel kalkınmanın
hayatlarına dokunmaya başladığını gördükçe
insanlar sahip çıkmaya başladılar.
İlk iş üretici pazarları kurduk, üretici
pazarlarının çok temel bir kuralı vardı.
Çünkü vatandaş üretimden
uzaklaşmaya başlamış
ve artık üretimden vazgeçmeye başlamıştı.
Onları teşvik edebilmek için
üretici pazarları kurduk
ve dedik ki hiçbir işgaliye, harç bir şey
almayacağız sizden ama
tek bir koşul var,
kendi ürettiğinizi satacaksınız.
Kendi ürettiklerini satmak konusunda
başlangıçta çok isteksiz olan vatandaşlar,
İzmirliler gelip gittikçe
üretmeye başladılar.
Onlar ürettikçe İzmirliler daha çok geldi
ve bu kartopu gibi birbirini büyüttü.
Bugün artık rengarenk tezgahlarda
ilk kez elma bahçesi var.
İlk kez patates yetiştiriliyor
Seferihisar'da.
Velhasıl üreticiler tekrar cesaret bulup
vazgeçtikleri veya artık terk ettikleri
üretim alanlarına dönmeye başladılar.
Örgütsüz güç güç değil dedik
ve onları örgüt çatısı altında
buluşturmaya çalıştık.
Yani birlik çatısı altında,
yani kooperatif çatısı altında
yaptığımız ilk iş
Mandalina Üretici Birliği'ni kurmak oldu.
Ardından onlar için bir işleme-paketleme
tesisi satın aldık.
Birliğe devrettik, ihracat yetkisi aldık.
Şu anda Türkiye'deki
ihracat yetkisi olan tek birlik
bizim Mandalina Üretici Birliğimiz.
Geçen sene ilk defa on beş tır,
Ukrayna'ya kendi bahçesinden
aracısız ürettiği mandalinayı
satabilir hale geldi.
Arkasından yerli tohumlarımıza
sahip çıkmaya çalıştık.
Çünkü biliyoruz ki,
bu topraklar binlerce yıl boyunca
en bereketli ürünlerini vermiş.
Tarım, Anadolu'da
başlamış insanlık tarihinde.
Dolayısıyla 2006 yılında çıkan
bir yasayla yasaklanan tohumları,
yerel tohumların satışını
tekrar koruyabilmek için,
yaşatabilmek için
tohum takas şenlikleri yapmaya başladık.
Orada elde ettiğimiz tohumları
kurduğumuz naylon seralarda fidelendirdik.
Sonra hem onları okul bahçelerinde
çocuklarımız için
sebze bahçeleri oluşturarak
yetiştirmeye başladık,
hem de tekrar köylülerimize vererek
eski tohumları tekrar
hayata geçirmelerini sağlamaya çalıştık.
Arkasından yaptığımız birkaç şeyden
daha çok kısaca bahsedeyim.
Bir doğa envanteri çalışması yaptık.
Doğa Derneği ile beraber Seferihisar'da
nasıl bir doğada yaşadığımızı
tespit etmemiz gerektiğini düşündük.
365 günlük bir çalışma sonunda
inanılmaz zengin orkide türlerine
sahip olduğumuzu gördük.
Muhteşem bitki türlerine
sahip olduğumuzu gördük,
farkında olmadığımızı anladık.
Velhasıl derya içinde olup
deryayı bilmeden yaşadığımızı gördük.
Bir doğa okulu açtık.
Bu hızla yaşadığımız dünyada
kadim kültürlerin unutulmaya başladığını,
hayatı bizle başlayıp biten
bir şey gibi yaşadığımızı biliyoruz.
O nedenle, o kadim kültürleri
tekrar ortaya çıkartacak,
ağaç aşılamaktan kerpiç duvara
hepsinin tekrar bilgisini
gün ışığına çıkartacak bir okul kurduk.
Son olarak, bir şeyden
daha bahsetmek isterim.
Pazar yerimiz vardı bizim.
Pazar yerimizin üzerini
fotovoltaik panelle kapladık.
Yanındaki belediye binamızın enerjisini
artık oradan sağlıyoruz.
Isıtmasını, soğutmasını,
tüm elektriğini oradan sağlıyoruz.
Bir de üstelik hafif hafif
para kazanmaya da başladık.
Özetle, şunu söylemeye çalışıyorum:
Doğanın momentumundan koptukça,
hız ve büyüklük fetişizmi ile
bir arada yaşamaya başlıyoruz.
Aslında mutsuz bir hayatı da
kendimiz için kurgulamaya başlıyoruz.
Yüzümüzü doğaya dönmeye başladıkça
hayatımız daha keyifli, daha huzurlu,
daha yaşanabilir bir hal alıyor.
Nazım'ın dediği gibi:
"Yaşamak şakaya gelmez.
Büyük bir ciddiyetle yaşayacaksın.
Yani, öyle ciddiyetle yaşayacaksın ki
sadece yaşamak olacak.
Yaşamanın ötesinde berisinde başka
bir beklentin olmayacak.
Yani öylesine
ciddiye alacaksın ki yaşamayı,
yetmişinde bile zeytin ağacı dikeceksin.
Hem de öyle çocuklara falan
kalır diye değil.
Ölümden korktuğun halde,
ölüme inanmadığın için,
yaşamak yani ağır bastığından."
Hepinize sabrınız için
çok teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkış)